how are you feeling today
yeah i mean um obviously it sucks um
to be voted out um but considering i'm
feeling pretty good um and i'm proud of
the game that i played
you were one of the final three women
left how does it feel to be in that
position
yeah i mean i think that was amazing uh
to be able to be one of the last three i
think it's you know always hard in the
season of survivor you know to make it
um especially as a woman and so um that
was really exciting to be kind of like a
part of that cohort and just be duking
it out and trying to stay in the game
so you were obviously blindsided with
the whole shan being voted out did that
kind of make you feel like you were
potentially next
yeah i mean oh my gosh yeah like i knew
going into this tribal council i was on
the hot seat and it very well could be
me um i think you know the sequence of
events that unfolded like really you
know didn't help my cause at all the
fact that it was you know do or die and
then you know danny got immunity all
this stuff so
um you know that didn't help my game but
um you know i knew after shannon went
home like you know now we're in the
minority which is why you know at the
you know when danny deshawn made that
decision at eight it made no sense to me
because i knew we had you know shannon
deshawn have these tensions and things
but you know at eight when you have the
majority it makes no sense to do that i
was like we can vote at eight together
and then you know after that we can have
world war two like let's go at it but
like it just didn't make sense to me so
it was just like a very you know strange
predicament to be in i feel like but i i
try to use you know whatever i could to
make it through that vote um
you know leveraging erica you know
harping on the fact that riccard was a
huge immunity threat uh immunity
challenge threat so um yeah i tried to
do the best i could
who do you think was the main person
behind the deciding factor to send you
home obviously with the um
the
the what it was called whatever deshawn
got last night
yeah it was the main thing but who do
you think kind of was the deciding
factor to rally for you
well
um and then at least they showed like
you know xander threw my name out but
like also i knew it would be between um
me and ricard no matter what and so i
knew you know um the contingent point
was erica and you know wherever erica
voted heather would vote so um i knew i
had to pull an america um and i think
she was thinking about the fact that
ricard was a huge immunity challenge
threat um but for whatever reason that
like wasn't in her best interest and she
chose me instead so
i mean also like you know the the um
extra vote that xander had as well like
that also you know contributed to it so
yeah
you said you were down for revenge after
shan left what would have been the
ultimate revenge for you this season in
survivor
yes um hmm i mean i wanted revenge for
like a couple things i think like the
danny and deshawn thing would have been
great but then also i mean it would have
been amazing if i mean you know it could
have gotten xander you know plays idol
like whatever like that was something
that had been brewing since i was at
yasa um so revenge could be like a lot
of things from me like that season but
um you know i think after you know that
that vote at eight and not being the
majority i had to work with daniel
deshawn even if i wanted revenge like i
needed to make it through this boat um
using them
and going back to the zander thing when
you guys were in tribal and he had the
fake idol
did that kind of like give you a shot to
your confidence or anything because you
were so confident you were going to get
him in that moment and he's like
actually i made this fake item yeah
um no yeah i think like that point for
me was honestly one of the biggest
points of growth for me in the game um
to be able to you know go in and be like
i'm going to make this move and i really
hope it works and then for it to
backfire you know i get home i give you
get back to camp and i'm like
really beating myself up over it but
then you know
i find some you know this resilience
within me to be like no it's like okay
like you're gonna live to fight another
day and i did i lasted so much longer
after that vote you know um and so i
think that's one of my proudest moments
in the game of like you know you you own
the moves you make i go up to every and
i'm like listen like i made this move
and like it was in the best interest of
my game i hope you understand that like
and you just keep playing and you just
get up and keep playing and so i think
that for me was like definitely one of
my proudest moments in the game
and it's better to be making moves and
not just sliding by right exactly that's
the moment people will remember that was
pretty good and it also gave xander his
little time to shine as well
yes
yeah that's so true um yeah and i think
like for that vote too i give a lot of
credit to evie and tiff
because you know they were the ones that
knew how my advantage worked and and and
and played it correctly um
xander was just the messenger really you
know what i mean i mean it's a cherry on
top it was like xander that did it out
of all people but you know i really
think folks got to give credit to evie
and tef too
how is your relationship like outside of
the game with your tribe now yeah
yeah i know i'm telling you like i
really wish they could have shown more
of yasa camp life because we're just so
fun um and so i'm really close with
evian tiff um talk to xander every now
and then too um so like the the four of
us really got to bond you know in those
weeks that you know um we were competing
in the immunity challenges to make it
all the way to merge so it's they're
great people outside the game too
you didn't compete in the immunity
challenge last night what was your
reasoning behind that
yeah so
this steward die you know like twist
was you know crazy and um for me you
know i didn't want to
um i hadn't done so hot in individual
immunity immunity challenges thus far
and so if i was you know the likelihood
of me dropping first is high and if i
did drop first i didn't want to go out
of the game you know based on a random
draw i wanted people to vote me out of
the game so i was like this doesn't make
the this doesn't make sense for me um
i'll likely be one of the first people
to drop i'm not doing this um so that
for me was you know an easy decision and
i definitely stand by it now too
do you have any regrets like maybe not
playing the shot in the dark any regrets
behind that
no because i thought really long and
hard about like every decision that i
make out
out there and i think given the
information i had those times i made the
best decisions for me with every piece
of information that i had um i think one
thing that like i i wish in in terms of
do and die the do or die twist i wish at
that tribal council we had more time to
to talk after we figured out the outcome
of deshaun's because then i would have
really harped in and went after ricard i
think
but it was very disorienting because of
everything that was going on
do you think anyone's sliding by right
now just staying in the shadows trying
not to get as much camera time
um
i mean i think like you know heather
like
i don't know i i mean it's up you know
to her to speak about it um but i'm not
sure what you know she's really you know
done so far um but still like outside
the amazing amazing person um just game
play wise like i don't know
but she's really really sweet woman
outside of the game
and tribal was extremely powerful last
night there was a lot of powerful
moments how did you feel taking part in
such an important conversation because
you even said i know some survivor fans
probably don't want to hear this right
now but i think it was really important
so how did you feel being part of such a
great moment
yeah i just think it was important you
know like like i think people say this
all the time but survivor is a microcosm
of the real world and we're real people
and this is something that's impacting
communities that i come from um
across the globe across america so um
you know i was proud to be able to talk
about that and to have that conversation
with america even if some people didn't
want to hear it um because it needed to
be said so um definitely very proud of
that moment um and it was really cool to
just see my have my family be able to
see it um and people that i love to be
able to see that because it represents
so much and so much that is not said
that needs to be said
this is such a great moment
this has been the hardest season so far
what has been the hardest part for you
yeah um i think like it cannot be
understated the fact that we didn't have
any rice or like any like
i can't tell you the amount of times
that i stood up out there and i would
get dizzy and tip would be like you know
sit down like we were just like when we
did challenges and stuff it was pure
adrenaline like we literally had no food
in our bodies um so
that was by far you know the hardest
thing to just stay mentally tough and
just be like no you gotta even when you
know you're starving and like when i you
know in the club that i say like leaving
the game i'm like i'm gonna go eat like
i was so excited to eat because it was
just it was so hard
that leads me into my next question for
you what did you eat because you were
hype about going to get and eat some
food oh my god yes i eat so much i ate
like a burger i ordered like french
fries they got me chocolate cake because
like i was like an inside joke that i
wanted chocolate cake as soon as i got
out of the game um i literally ate
everything like we i ordered so much i
learned multiple things and i was just
stuffing my face
would you do it all again
yes i know it's crazy but like i love
survivor um i'm addicted to this show
i've watched it ever since i was a
little girl like i think i would
yeah would you do any other reality
shows like the challenge or anything
like that because i feel like you and
shannon could do that together
i don't know i mean i really like i'm
really biased like i really like
survivor is my show and so like if i
didn't have that like love for it i
don't know that i would but yeah
my last question for you is what advice
would you give others who want to be on
survivor to play survivor and they just
don't think that they would be picked
yeah
take your shot in the dark literally
like just do it you know like um
survivor was my dream i you know was
like you know this is something that i
want to do do it and you can do it and
do it being whoever you are whatever
that represents i think that's super
important because like you see like you
know america deserves to know each and
every one of you and who you are in your
story so i think it's important